this picture by a British journalist is  said to show one of the Russian armored  personnel carriers that crossed into  Ukraine late Thursday I'm very alarmed  by reports that Russian military  vehicles may have crossed the border  this morning of course the humanitarian  convoy itself is a separate issue but if  there are any Russian military personnel  or vehicles in eastern Ukraine they need  to be withdrawn immediately or the  consequences could be very serious not  too far away an official Russian convoy  is thought to still be stuck at the  border Moscow says it is varying aid as  a goodwill gesture for Ukrainians but  the government in Kiev fears military  equipment for the separatists could be  hidden onboard reports say Ukrainian  officials have now inspected the convoy  if the trucks are cleared to travel on  the Red Cross will take charge of  distributing their cargo